Hi!
Terry Liskevych, head coach of Oregon State,...
...former USA national Women's coach.
I've always felt that serving is a very important skill.
It's the only skill that you control in volleyball.
In teaching serving to your teams,...
...the first thing you ought to do at a very young age...
...is teach people to get the ball over the net.
The first thing I would do is teach a sidearm serve...
...so that, you could teach somebody just hitting the ball sidearm...
...so they don't have to tax their shoulder, I teach a sidearm floater.
Then, the next serve we would really emphasize is a standing float serve,...
...and that's where you're standing on the floor,...
...tossing the ball in front of you, hitting the center of the ball...
...to make the ball float over the net.
Other variations that you can teach your team are standing on the floor,...
...having a topspin serve, where you're tossing the ball at the back of you,...
...hitting the ball with topspin over the net.
And the final two serves are a jump float,...
...where you're jumping off the ground and hitting a float serve,...
...and then finally is a jump topspin.
This is a serve that has the most velocity so that's what you want.